This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客。百分之二的保证。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们在奇妙的现代世界中培养坚韧意志、体能和抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历这一切后变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2”。请在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。相信我，宝贝。在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎收听《回首过往》播客。对1979年来说，那对我是个重大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同行喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
请在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回首过往》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《艰难一课》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就非得这么做。请在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《艰难一课》。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Guys, it's a big one today. I just have to prepare you. We're going to talk about rock bottom. We're going to talk about that moment where you kind of look around at your life and you think,
大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这是一档探讨我们二十岁时面临的一些重大生活变化与转折，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听友、老听友，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴能在这里欢迎大家回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们要剖析二十岁时的心理学。伙计们，今天这个话题分量很重。我必须先给你们打个预防针。我们要谈谈人生的谷底。我们要谈谈那种你环顾自己的生活，然后心想的时刻，
how the hell did I get here? Not in like the cute rom-con style sense, but in that stomach-dropping way where everything feels like it has collapsed at once. Maybe you've lost your job or the relationship you thought would last forever has just ended or you are staring at your bank account and the balance can't even cover rent or all three of those things are happening at once. Or maybe nothing dramatic has happened, but you just woke up one day and realized, hey, I don't even recognize myself anymore. I don't even like myself. And I definitely don't like my life. That is exactly what we are diving in today. That moment, that pit in the stomach is what so many of us call rock bottom, that destruction. We're going to talk about everything to do with this infamous low point.
我到底是怎么落到这田地的？不是那种浪漫喜剧风格的可爱感觉，而是那种让你心往下沉、感觉一切同时崩塌的方式。也许你失业了，或者你以为会天长地久的感情刚刚结束，又或者你盯着银行账户，余额甚至付不起房租，或者这三件事同时发生了。或者也许没有发生什么戏剧性的事情，但你只是某天醒来突然意识到，嘿，我甚至再也认不出自己了。我甚至都不喜欢自己。而且我绝对不喜欢我的生活。这正是我们今天要深入探讨的内容。那一刻，胃里翻江倒海的感觉就是我们许多人所说的生活谷底，那种毁灭。我们将讨论与这个声名狼藉的低谷有关的一切。
some of the examples that I can give you, including some from you guys, the listeners, why we get to that point, how we get to that point, as well as looking at how we might interpret Rock Bottom a little bit differently to hopefully maybe see it as a little bit of a springboard, or maybe as something positive, if that's even possible. The question I'm really just interested in is, is Rock Bottom actually a fresh start? Is it actually a bit of a trampoline?
我可以举出一些例子，包括你们这些听众的例子，我们为什么会到达那个点，我们是如何到达那个点的，以及探讨我们如何能对“谷底”做出一点不同的解读，希望能把它看作是一个跳板，或者如果可能的话，把它看作是一件积极的事情。我真正感兴趣的问题是，谷底其实是一个全新的开始吗？它其实是一个小小的蹦床吗？
or is it a place that we actually all need to get to at some point in our life in order to move to the next chapter? We're going to talk about it together. We're going to talk about as well addiction, the dark night of the soul, if you've heard of that concept, how psychology and spirituality really intersect at rock bottom, chronic illness, so many other things. This episode is broad and wide. If any of you resonate with this topic at the moment, I'm so glad you're here. I'm sending you so much love. I see you. I hear you.
还是说，为了进入下一个章节，它是我们在人生某个阶段都必须要去到的地方？我们将一起讨论这个话题。我们还将讨论成瘾、灵魂的黑夜（如果你听说过这个概念的话），心理学和灵学如何在人生谷底交汇，慢性病等等许多其他事情。这一期节目内容广泛。如果你们当中有人目前对这个话题感同身受，我很高兴你们在这里。我向你们发送满满的爱。我看见了你们。我听见了你们。
I'm glad this has found you. And I will metaphorically hold your hand through the microphone, through the screen for this episode. And I really hope that what we talk about today will provide some solace or maybe just a little bit of understanding in what I'm sure is a very confusing, very strange time. I promise it won't last forever. I have been there. And maybe just maybe it is preparing you for something more.
我很高兴这个节目能被你听到。在这期节目中，我将透过麦克风、透过屏幕，像是在精神上握住你的手。我真心希望我们今天讨论的内容能提供一些慰藉，或者在这个我确信非常困惑、非常奇怪的时期，能带来一点理解。我向你们保证，这不会持续永远。我也曾经历过。也许，仅仅是也许，它正在为你准备更美好的事物。
Let's explore that possibility. So without further ado, let's get into the psychology of rock bottom. I think part of the reason this idea of rock bottom resonates with so many of us is because we all kind of know what it feels like or we've seen it. It's also incredibly personal. There isn't one objective definition. Your rock bottom might not look like mine and mine might not look like yours. I know that my rock bottom happened in 2021.
让我们来探讨这种可能性。废话不多说，让我们进入谷底心理学。我认为人们之所以对“谷底”这个概念产生共鸣，部分原因是因为我们都大致知道那种感觉是什么样的，或者我们曾目睹过。它也非常具有个人色彩。并没有一个客观的定义。你的谷底可能和我的不一样，我的也可能和你的不一样。我知道我的谷底发生在2021年。
I definitely talked about this, but I went through two devastating breakups in one year, literally within nine months of each other. I lost about 50% of my friends in the three months after I moved cities, where I moved cities to a place where I didn't have a job, I didn't have anything to do, I didn't know anybody, my mental health was terrible, my bank account was a disaster, I was lonely, I was tired, I was lost, and I can admit now I was probably drinking a little bit too much, and everything was just going wrong.
我肯定谈过这个，但在一年里我经历了两次毁灭性的分手，字面意思是在短短九个月内接连发生。在我搬到另一个城市后的三个月里，我失去了大约50%的朋友，我搬到一个没有工作、没事可做、谁也不认识的地方，我的心理健康状况极糟，我的银行账户一团糟，我感到孤独、疲惫、迷失，而且我现在可以承认，我当时可能喝得有点太多了，一切都在出错。
I also infamously had another moment like this last year. I've spoken about my mental breakdown in a couple of episodes. And that was another really low rock bottom point. And I know it sounds weird to say I'm sure that I could probably go lower someday. Part of me thinks that there is another rock bottom waiting for me. Is it terrifying? Yes, I think part of it is also exciting and I'll explain why. So that was my experience. And, you know, that's just one person. For another person, it could be. be an addiction spiraling out of control. For another, it's like a quiet collapse of your sense of purpose. One person DM'd me about finding out that her boyfriend had cheated on her the same day she got fired. Another person said it was when she realized she was in a cult. Losing a parent to cancer was another one. Someone said when they realized they were only confident when they blacked out
去年我同样遭遇了另一个臭名昭著的时刻。我在好几期节目中都谈到过我的精神崩溃。那是另一个非常低谷的时刻。我知道这样说听起来很奇怪，但我确信有一天我可能还会跌得更低。我内心的一部分觉得，另一个谷底正在等待着我。这很可怕吗？是的，但我认为其中一部分也令人兴奋，我会解释原因。所以这就是我的经历。而且，你知道，那只是一个人。对另一个人来说，它可能是。失控的成瘾。对另一个人来说，则是你人生目标的一种悄然崩塌。有个粉丝私信我说，她在被解雇的同一天发现男友出轨了。另一个人说，那是她意识到自己身处一个邪教组织的时候。因为癌症失去父母是又一个例子。有人说，当他们意识到自己只有在断片时才自信时
or when they had to move back home with their parents after going into a lot of debt for college. And yet all these are very different, right? But when people talk about them, there are these shared threads, these like common emotional fingerprints that help us know, okay, I'm here. This looks like bottom to me. This is the bottom. It can't get any worse than that. Or then what it is right now. Psychologists will tell you there are certain markers that come up again and again when people come into their offices and describe their lowest points. The first and perhaps the biggest is a loss of control and a loss of sense of self. Maybe you were once the ambitious one, the reliable one, the one who had it all together. And now it feels like
或者在为大学背负了巨额债务后，不得不搬回父母家住。然而所有这些都截然不同，对吧？但当人们谈论它们时，却有着这些共同的线索，这些共同的情感指纹，帮助我们确认，好吧，我到这里了。在我看来，这就是谷底。这就是最低点。不可能比这更糟了。或者比现在更糟了。心理学家会告诉你，当人们走进他们的办公室并描述他们的最低点时，会出现一些反复出现的特定标志。第一个，也许也是最大的标志，就是失去控制和失去自我感。也许你曾经是有雄心壮志的那个人，是可靠的那个人，是一切都处理得井井有条的那个人。而现在感觉就像是，
where is that person? You can barely recognize yourself in the mirror. You're not making decisions anymore. Life is just kind of happening to you. There was a 2016 paper published in the journal Academy of Management Review and it used this phrase to refer to facing rock bottom. It used this phrase, the crystallization of discontent. The crystallization of discontent, fancy word, but it basically means this point where you just feel a total sense of loss. You feel a loss of self, you feel social disorientation, even failure. And the authors say that this leads to this feeling that you don't even have an identity. It's that really painful moment when you realize that who you are on the inside and who you are in the world
那个人在哪里？你在镜子里几乎认不出自己了。你不再做决定了。生活只是在你身上发生着。2016年《管理学会评论》杂志发表了一篇论文，它用这个词来指代面对人生的谷底。它用了这个词，不满的结晶。不满的结晶，这是一个华丽的词，但它基本上意味着这样一种时刻，你只感到一种彻底的失落感。你感到失去自我，你感到社交迷失方向，甚至是失败。作者说，这导致了一种你甚至没有身份认同的感觉。那是那个非常痛苦的时刻，当你意识到你内心的那个你和你在这个世界上的那个你，
do not line up and maybe you can't find your way back to who you really feel or think that you are or who you were in the past. That's the first marker. The next marker is an inability to imagine the future. At rock bottom, time feels very slow and very sticky. You can't really see beyond the next day sometimes. Maybe you can't even see beyond the next hour. You can't picture it getting better. You can't picture yourself ever not feeling how you feel right now. Psychologists studying depression describe this as future discounting. Future discounting is where distress literally makes it harder for your brain to project yourself into tomorrow. I'll be the first one to tell you. Even if you can't believe it right now, I promise you this feeling won't last forever. It's just the current state that you're
并不相符，也许你再也找不到回真正让你感觉或认为的那个自己，或者过去那个自己的路了。这是第一个标志。下一个标志是无法想象未来。在人生的谷底，时间感觉非常慢、非常粘稠。有时你真的看不到第二天之后的事。也许你甚至看不到一个小时之后的事。你无法想象事情会变好。你无法想象自己永远不会再有现在这种感觉。研究抑郁症的心理学家将此描述为未来贴现。未来贴现是指痛苦从字面上让你的大脑更难将自己投射到明天。我会第一个告诉你。即使你现在无法相信，我向你保证，这种感觉不会永远持续下去。这只是你目前所处的状态，
in that is convincing you that it will. So there's this future discounting. Then there's helplessness and regret. Maybe you've tried to fix things over and over. You've tried to get your drinking under control. You've tried to find your way back on the right path, but nothing has worked. And now you feel like similar to what we said before, it never will. This connects directly to Martin Siegelman's idea of learned helplessness. Learned helplessness. We've talked about it the podcast before, this is a psychological state where after we basically experience a number of really stressful events or life experiences, especially experiences where we feel like we have no control, we basically just assume that we don't and we give up. We get so tired of trying over
它在说服你这会持续下去。所以这就是未来贴现。接着是无助和遗憾。也许你曾一次又一次地试图修复事情。你曾试图控制你的饮酒。你曾试图找回走上正轨的路，但什么都没用。现在你觉得，类似于我们之前说过的，事情永远不会好转了。这直接联系到马丁·塞利格曼关于习得性无助的概念。习得性无助。我们以前在播客里谈论过，这是一种心理状态，在基本上经历了一系列非常负面的事件或生活经历后，尤其是那些让我们觉得无能为力的经历，我们基本上就会认为自己无能为力并选择放弃。我们厌倦了一次又一次地尝试，
and over just for the outcome to stay the same that we stop trying. Even when there are steps presented to us, even when someone from the outside could say, well, this is exactly what you need to do. We just can't see it. And finally, the final marker of Rock Bottom often is associated with some kind of collapse. Relationship breakdown, financial hardship, burnout, chronic illness. Sometimes it's all these things at once. That collapse can feel like a life demolition. Everything you thought was holding you up. Everything that you were relying on has crumbled. And you're kind of left standing in the rubble being like,
结果却依然如故，于是我们停止了尝试。即使摆在我们面前有解决的步骤，即使外人可以说，嗯，这正是你需要做的。我们就是看不见。最后，谷底的最后一个标志通常与某种崩溃有关。关系破裂、经济困境、职业倦怠、慢性病。有时是所有这些事情同时发生。这种崩溃会让人感觉像是生活的拆迁。你以为支撑着你的一切。你所依赖的一切都瓦尔解了。而你有点像站在废墟中，心想，
where do I even start right now? Like what is the first thing I need to rebuild when everything is on fire? So maybe you're listening to this and thinking, oh yeah, that's totally me right now. I'm in that moment. Maybe you've been there before. Maybe you're terrified of ending up there one day. Whatever you are thinking wherever you're thinking wherever you,
现在我该从哪里开始呢？当一切都在燃烧时，我需要重建的第一件事是什么？所以也许你在听这个，然后心想，哦是的，这完全就是现在的我。我正处于那个时刻。也许你以前去过那里。也许你很害怕有一天会落到那种地步。无论你在想什么，无论你在想什么，无论你，
you are right now, whatever you are feeling right now, I think it's important to recognize rock bottom is not permanent. It is absolutely not. People cannot live their whole lives in a permanent rock bottom. We're going to discuss that a little bit more later on. But I just want to give you that reminder so that if rock bottom is where you are right now, as we go into why this maybe has happened to you, you have a little bit of hope for the future. So, if you are in this place, you might be asking yourself, like, how did I end up here? When did this begin? One significant cause of rock bottom is that we may have just experienced the entire collapse of our identity and our self-concept. This happens actually quite frequently when we first reach adulthood.
你现在身处何地，无论你现在感受到了什么，我认为认识到谷底并不是永久的是很重要的。绝对不是。人们不可能一辈子都生活在永久的谷底。我们稍后会对此进行更多讨论。但我只想给你这个提醒，这样如果谷底正是你现在所处的地方，当我们深入探讨为什么这可能会发生在你身上时，你对未来还会有一点希望。所以，如果你正处于这个地方，你可能会问自己，我到底是怎么落到这里的？这一切是什么时候开始的？导致谷底的一个重要原因是，我们可能刚刚经历了身份认同和自我概念的彻底崩塌。这种情况实际上在我们刚成年时相当频繁地发生。
A particularly useful lens for us to understand is this idea from Jennifer Campbell of self-concept clarity. Self-concept clarity is essentially how clearly and confidently you are able to say who you are or able to identify who you are. It's the difference between someone who can describe their values, describe their priorities, have a sense of consistency within their goals and how they act versus someone who feels like they are living out seven different identities and that their whole life is fragmented. When people hit rock bottom, this clarity of self-concept often plummets. Your sense of identity, the lens through which you interpret the world, becomes deeply unstable. We can see why that happens a lot in our 20s because things are shifting so rapidly.
对我们来说，一个特别有用的理解视角是詹妮弗·坎贝尔关于自我概念清晰度的观点。自我概念清晰度本质上是指你能多么清晰、自信地说出你是谁，或者能够识别你是谁。这就像是一个能够描述自己的价值观、描述自己的优先事项、在目标和行为方式上有一种一致性的人，与一个觉得自己过着七种不同身份的生活、整个生活支离破碎的人之间的区别。当人们跌入谷底时，这种自我概念的清晰度往往会骤降。你的身份感、你解读世界的镜头变得极其不稳定。我们可以看出为什么这种情况在我们的二十岁时经常发生，因为事情变化得太快了。
things that we often rest a lot of our identity on, like our relationship, like what school we go to, like our job, like our family. And because you don't have anything to anchor yourself to, your internal compass gets kind of thrown off the mark. Now, if you have high self-concept clarity, it's not just that you know who you are. It's that you also know what you need. So you are actively able to seek social support. are actively able to see your way out of a crisis to nourish good quality relationships. It might not be that surprising, but research consistently ties low clarity with mental health difficulties and loneliness and also things like anxiety and depression. This is all contributing to this feeling of being at rock bottom. You can see why maybe this has a lot to do with just
我们常常将大量身份寄托其上的事物，比如我们的恋爱关系、我们上的学校、我们的工作、我们的家庭。正因为你没有任何可以锚定自己的东西，你的内部指南针就会有点偏离方向。现在，如果你拥有很高的自我概念清晰度，这不仅意味着你知道你是谁。这也意味着你知道你需要什么。所以你能够积极地寻求社会支持。能够积极地看到走出危机的方法，去滋养高质量的关系。这也许并不令人意外，但研究一致表明，低清晰度与心理健康困难、孤独感以及焦虑和抑郁等问题息息相关。这一切都导致了这种处于谷底的感觉。你可以看出为什么这可能与
the decade that you're in, that this is just something that you don't have to experience, but A lot of people are for very similar reasons. Another significant pathway to rock bottom and something that I feel links to losing a sense of identity is living in a passive state. This is often described in psychology as having an external locus of control. This is where we basically end up maybe unconsciously perceiving life as something that happens to us rather than something that we can influence. So you might drift through your days feeling like decisions are kind of imposed on you,
你所处的十年有很大关系，这不仅是你不需要经历的事情，而且许多人出于非常相似的原因正在经历它。通往谷底的另一个重要途径，也是我觉得与失去身份感有关的事情，就是生活在一种被动状态中。这在心理学上通常被描述为具有外控型人格。在这种状态下，我们可能最终会在无意中将生活视为发生在我们身上的事情，而不是我们能够影响的事情。所以你可能会浑浑噩噩地过日子，觉得各种决定都是强加给你的，
that everyone else has these opportunities and they're just kind of passing you by, that every little thing you try to get out of your situation does not work. Over time, this sense of passivity accumulates stress and kind of creates a slow motion resignation to life. Again, studies have shown that adults with an external locus of control, are more prone to anxiety, depression, and learned helplessness, particularly during major life transitions like those that are common in our 20s. In real life, what that means is that you know you hate your job, but you feel like you can't leave, there's no other option.
其他所有人都有这些机会，而这些机会只是从你身边擦肩而过，你为了摆脱困境所尝试的每一个小方法都不起作用。随着时间的推移，这种被动感会积聚压力，并对生活产生一种缓慢的顺从。同样，研究表明，具有外控型人格的成年人更容易出现焦虑、焦虑症、抑郁和习得性无助，尤其是在重大生活转折期间，比如在我们二十岁时常见的那些转折。在现实生活中，这意味着你知道你讨厌你的工作，但你觉得自己无法离开，没有别的选择。
You know you don't like your relationship or your friendships, but you feel like you will never find anything or anyone better. You know that your mental health is spiraling. You know that you're more anxious than you've ever been. you know that things are going wrong, but for some reason you cannot seem to find a solution. Small choices get deferred until suddenly you wake up and you feel trapped, which is of course the predecessor to hitting rock bottom. When looking into the research on this topic, a lot of it centered around the role of addiction.
你知道你不喜欢你的恋爱关系或友情，但你觉得自己永远找不到更好的人或事。你知道你的心理健康正在螺旋式下降。你知道你比以往任何时候都更焦虑。你知道事情正在出错，但出于某种原因，你似乎找不到解决方案。微小的选择被一拖再拖，直到你突然醒来，感觉自己被困住了，这当然是跌入谷底的前兆。在研究这个主题的研究时，很多研究都集中在成瘾的角色上。
And this can really be caused by and contribute to a lot of the factors that we've already mentioned before and I'm not just talking about an addiction to certain substances. I'm talking about addiction to chaos, addiction to a certain kind of relationship, addiction to a certain person. Before we get into this, I feel like this is a whole new chapter for this episode. So we are going to take a short break. Go get a cup of tea, go wash some dishes. We will be right back. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also a cup of tea. We'll watch some dishes. We will be right back. 2%. 2%. That is the number of people. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also and escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%,
这实际上可能是由我们之前已经提到的许多因素引起的，并助长了这些因素，我指的不仅仅是对某些物质的成瘾。我指的是对混乱的成瘾，对某种关系的成瘾，对某个人的成瘾。在我们深入探讨这个之前，我觉得这是这期节目全新的一章。所以我们将进行短暂的休息。去泡杯茶，去洗洗盘子。我们马上回来。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。去泡杯茶。去洗洗盘子。我们马上回来。2%。2%。这就是人数比例。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
我将剖析我们在奇妙的现代世界中培养坚韧意志、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越统治健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
我们真的相信种子油本质上会导致发炎。我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历这一切后变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
即在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回首过往》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through. line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
在每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，大谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时准备聊聊可卡因，但只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，到目前为止，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二期节目。所以我开始看出这里有一条红线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆上桌面了。谢谢你把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a day. decade of my own experience in the middle health field and conversations with so many incredible guests i'm talking trip fontaine ryan clark sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing
是的。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。请在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回首过往》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难一课》，我是主持人兼你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行对话，我邀请了特里·方丹、瑞安·克拉克有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太专注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它，
and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses steve burns dustin ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scan.
我们却还在追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们在给生活记分，生活变成了输赢，史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯因为你觉得在人间做个好人很重要？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹只是去做一个好人。和我基尔·盖恩斯一起，在我的新播客《艰难一课》中，就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己陷入了一场亲子鉴定风波。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这引发了长达数年的诉讼战以证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一群互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges.
另外两名经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天哪。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。
This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. We basically, like we can't talk about rock bottom without talking about addiction. Someone even say that the addiction space is where the idea of rock bottom was really like invented or given a name. It is one of the most powerful pathways to this moment or this period of despair and loss and just like fragmentation. Not just because of the behaviors themselves, but because of the cascading kind of effects addiction will have on every part of our life. again we're not just talking about substances here we're not just talking about alcohol or drugs or gambling or whatever it is there are so many things relationships situations that we can become addicted to
在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没结束。请在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。基本上，就像我们不谈论成瘾就无法谈论谷底一样。甚至有人说，成瘾领域才是真正“发明”或赋予“谷底”这个概念名称的地方。它是通往这一时刻或绝望、失落以及支离破碎的时期最有力的途径之一。不仅仅是因为行为本身，而是因为成瘾将对我们生活的各个部分产生的级联效应。再次强调，我们在这里谈论的不仅仅是物质，我们谈论的不仅仅是酒精、毒品、赌博或其他什么，有太多事情、关系、情况是我们可能会上瘾的，
because in some sense they give us a feeling of being actually very alive and when everything's going wrong sometimes that's the only feeling we want a lot of neuroscience research especially the work of the national institute on drug abuse shows that that addiction of any form rewires the brain's reward systems. Normally, dopamine helps us feel motivated. We know it makes us feel satisfied when we meet our goals. We know it helps us experience pleasure. But what addiction does is hijack this system,
因为在某种意义上，它们给了我们一种真正活着的真实感觉，而当一切都在出错时，有时这是我们唯一想要的感觉。大量的神经科学研究，特别是国家药物滥用研究所的工作表明，任何形式的成瘾都会重塑大脑的奖赏系统。通常，多巴胺帮助我们感到有动力。我们知道当我们达到目标时它会让我们感到满足。我们知道它能帮助我们体验快乐。但成瘾所做的是劫持这个系统，
making it so that the substance that we are engaging in or the behavior or the relationship or the situation is the primary source of reward. And so over time, everyday activities that used to bring you joy, like spending time with your friends, exercising, accomplishing goals, hobbies, they lose their appeal. They can't give you the same hit that the substance or this thing can give you. So as natural rewards or long-term rewards lose meaning, self-regulation through those things becomes harder and harder. So the only resource we have left or the only coping strategy is to engage in the addictive behavior, even when it is clearly causing us harm. And with that tension of knowing something is damaging us but feeling unable to stop, it is very easy to see how that spirals and spirals into rock bottom.
使得我们参与的物质、行为、关系或情况成为奖赏的主要来源。因此，随着时间的推移，以前能给你带来快乐的日常活动，比如和朋友共度时光、锻炼、实现目标、爱好，都失去了吸引力。它们无法带给你像那种物质或事物能带给你的那种快感。因此，随着自然奖赏或长期奖赏失去意义，通过这些事情进行自我调节变得越来越困难。所以我们剩下的唯一资源或唯一的应对策略就是参与成瘾行为，即使它显然在对我们造成伤害。伴随着这种明知某事正在损害我们却又无法停下的紧张感，非常容易看出这如何螺旋式上升并最终跌入谷底。
The addictive behaviors basically begin to dominate everything. They dominate, obviously, our life, but they dominate that through our time, through our energy, through what we think. about meaning that it kind of is like a balloon that is expanding in a tight space that leaves not much room for anything else. We also know it erodes the social and structural scaffolding of a fulfilled life. Relationships really do suffer under addictive tension. You know, addiction can lead us to break people's trust, to be irritable, to neglect our relationship, to have arguments, It can also lead to tension at work. You know, jobs may be lost, bills go unpaid, health deteriorates.
成瘾行为基本上开始主导一切。它们显然主导了我们的生活，但它们通过我们的时间、我们的精力、我们的想法来主导这一点。这意味着它有点像一个在一个狭小空间里不断膨胀的气球，几乎没有留给其他任何东西的空间。我们也知道它会侵蚀充实生活的社会和结构支架。人际关系确实在成瘾的紧张状态下饱受折磨。你知道，成瘾会导致我们打破人们的信任、变得烦躁、忽视我们的关系、发生争吵，它还可能导致工作上的紧张。你知道，工作可能会失去，账单无法支付，健康状况恶化。
And as these external supports collapse, people often feel very, very alone, as though the world is closing in. And that's where rock bottom hits at that intersection of internal and external breakdown. Your rewired brain is craving the addictive substance or behavior. And then you also are no longer grounded by support or by things outside. side of the addiction, it's very easy to kind of float away with it. Addiction is obviously a very fast-track pathway to this. You don't have to have experienced an addiction in order to feel rock bottom. But it definitely, I think, is a great way of demonstrating how it's this culmination of a lot of things that pushes people to the edge. I will also say rock bottom rarely happens
随着这些外部支持的崩溃，人们往往会感到非常非常孤独，仿佛世界正在合拢。这就是谷底在内部和外部崩溃交汇处袭来的地方。你被重塑的大脑渴望着成瘾的物质或行为。然后你也不再受到成瘾之外的支持或事物的支撑，非常容易随波逐流。成瘾显然是通往这一境地的一条快车道。你不需要经历过成瘾才能感受到谷底。但它绝对是展示它是如何成为将人们推向边缘的众多事物累积的绝佳方式。我也要说，谷底很少在一夜之间发生。人们可能会经历极其严重的悲剧，而谷底实际上直到几天、几周、几个月后才真正出现，那时他们才意识到自己失去了什么，或者当他们意识到生活中已经消失的其他所有事情时。所以更多时候，它是压力的逐渐累积，被某些生活事件、关系破裂、心理崩溃所放大，所有这些似乎同时袭来。
overnight. People can experience severe, severe tragedy and rock bottom doesn't actually occur until days, weeks, months later when they realize what they've lost or when they realize all the other things that have kind of disappeared from their life. So more often than not, it is a gradual accumulation of strain magnified by certain life events, by relationship breakdown, by psychological breakdown, all kind of coming at once. So this is why you might sometimes hear psychologists refer to or compare hitting rock bottom to experiencing trauma because similar to when we experience trauma, it can often trigger a state of survival mode. We can be so overwhelmed with kind of what's going on around us or within us that we either switch into the state of being on constant high alert and hypervigilance or alternatively we can completely shut down. At rock bottom, you feel these huge emotions, sadness, despair, shame, guilt, maybe, anxiety, of course.
这就是为什么有时你会听到心理学家将跌入谷底比作经历创伤的原因，因为类似于我们经历创伤时，它通常会触发一种生存模式的状态。我们可能会被周围或内心发生的事情压得喘不过气来，以至于我们要么进入高度戒备和极度警觉的状态，要么完全关闭自己。在谷底，你感受到了这些巨大的情绪，悲剧、绝望、羞耻、内疚、也许还有焦虑，当然。
But equally, you might actually feel nothing. Might feel completely apathetic because at the base of it, what's really happening is that we feel out of control. And if we would have meaningfully try and engage with all the things that are happening in our life right now, it would overwhelm us so completely we don't think that we could manage and so we just kind of turn our back to it. It's not a deliberate thing, it's a survival strategy. And here's where it gets complicated because, yeah, that really sucks and that's really awful and our life is falling apart. But sometimes people interpret rock bottom as kind of a good thing. Some people talk about it like it is kind of necessary.
但同样，你可能实际上什么也感觉不到。可能会感到完全冷漠，因为归根结底，真正发生的事情是我们感到失控。如果我们有意义地尝试参与生活中正在发生的所有事情，它会彻底压垮我们，让我们觉得无法应对，所以我们只是背对它。这不是故意为之，而是一种生存策略。这就是复杂的地方，因为，是的，这真的很糟糕，这真的很可怕，我们的生活正在分崩离析。但有时人们将谷底解读为一件好事。有些人谈论它时，好像它是某种必要的东西。
it's a kind of force that demands confrontation with ourselves. We have to get to this point in order to confront deeper things that we may never actually look face on. So you may have heard of this phrase, the Dark Night of the Soul. It originates from a poem from like thousands of years ago, maybe hundreds of years ago, like the 16th century, by St. John of the Cross. He was the Spanish priest. and he basically used this phrase to describe a spiritual phase where God withdrew his comfort, leaving people feeling lost and alone.
这是一种迫使我们面对自己的力量。我们必须到达这个点，才能面对那些我们可能从未正视过的更深层次的事情。所以你可能听说过这个短语，“灵魂的黑夜”。它起源于几千年前的一首诗，也许是几百年前，比如16世纪，由圣十字若望所写。他是一位西班牙神父。他基本上用这个短语来描述一个精神阶段，在这个阶段中，上帝收回了他的安慰，让人感到迷失和孤独。
With this idea in mind, it was kind of believed that this was a necessary path for spiritually or religious people where they had to kind of shed self-reliance and any existing detachments they had in their life to have a deeper connection with God. God puts them in this terrible hard place so that they're not. find him. Of course, that is a very religious and spiritually heavy meaning, but psychologists and spiritual thinkers nowadays use it to describe a lot more than just a spiritual epiphany. It's where everything in life kind of falls apart and we are compelled to really confront who we really are. Kaoyung suggests that these dark nights are actually unavoidable psychological rights of passage
带着这个想法，人们曾认为这是精神或宗教人士的一条必经之路，他们必须抛弃对自我的依赖和他们生活中存在的任何超然，以便与上帝建立更深层次的联系。上帝把他们放在这个可怕的艰难地方，这样他们就不会找不到他。当然，这是一个具有很强的宗教和精神色彩的含义，但今天的心理学家和精神思想家用它来描述的不仅仅是精神上的顿悟。这就是生活中一切都崩溃，我们被迫真正面对我们究竟是谁的时候。荣格认为，这些黑夜实际上是不可避免的心理成长仪式，
that force us to face what he calls the shadow aspects of ourselves. The shadow aspects of ourselves are the thoughts, impulses, fears, patterns, parts of our identity that we habitually ignore or deny that are secretly sabotaging us. And he argued that if we don't ever have these moments of confronting them, the shadow will continue to control us unconsciously. And so it's through these painful moments that, we are able to actually confront these messier parts of us that are not working.
迫使我们面对他所谓的我们自身的阴暗面。我们自身的阴暗面是那些我们习惯性忽视或否认的、暗中破坏我们的思想、冲动、恐惧、模式、身份认同的一部分。他认为，如果我们从不经历这些面对它们的时刻，阴暗面将继续在无意识中控制我们。因此，正是通过这些痛苦的时刻，我们才能够真正面对我们身上那些不起作用的、更凌乱的部分。
You may have heard the name Victor Frankel. He is a Holocaust survivor and a psychologist. And he wrote this book, Man Search for Meaning. And in this book, he basically argued that even when life strips us of almost everything, our freedom, security, purpose, family, there remains one freedom we can never lose, which is the ability to. to choose how we respond. And so rock bottom in the sense, at this existential crossroads, basically is when we find ourselves
你可能听说过维克多·弗兰克尔这个名字。他是一位大屠杀幸存者和心理学家。他写了一本书《活出意义来》。在这本书中，他基本上认为，即使生活剥夺了我们几乎所有的一切，我们的自由、安全、目标、家庭，仍然有一种我们永远无法失去的自由，那就是选择如何回应的能力。所以从某种意义上说，在人生的这个存在主义十字路口，谷底基本上就是我们发现自己的时刻。
and our true power clearer than we've ever noticed it before. Basically, when the external world collapses, you are forced to dig deep and find true meaning internally, as paradoxical as it sounds, rock bottom is actually a real fertile ground for growth, purpose, a renewed sense of direction. So if we look at it in this light, you know, maybe this is the place where momentum actually begins. There's a blank page in front of you. You've been gifted the chance to start over.
我们真正的力量比以往任何时候都更加清晰。基本上，当外部世界崩溃时，你被迫深入挖掘并在内部找到真正的意义，正如听起来那样矛盾，谷底其实是成长、寻找目标、重新明确方向的绝佳肥沃土壤。所以如果我们从这个角度来看，你知道，也许这正是动力真正开始的地方。你面前有一张空白的页。你被赋予了重新开始的机会。
And whilst that blank page is terrifying, it can also be liberating. Modern psychology echoes this through the idea of post-traumatic growth. We know post-traumatic stress. Post-traumatic growth, though, is a concept that kind of came to light in the 90s that suggested that people who endure profound struggle from trauma to illness to loss to major life changes to addiction often report significant positive changes afterwards. This might include things like a deeper appreciation of life, stronger relationships, new priorities, heightened sense of personal strength, and sometimes even a real deep spiritual development. Of course, this is not always going to be the case.
虽然那张空白的页很可怕，但它也可能是解放性的。现代心理学通过创伤后成长的理念呼应了这一点。我们知道创伤后应激。然而，创伤后成长是一个在90年代崭露头角的概念，它表明那些经历过从创伤到疾病、从失落到重大生活变故再到成瘾等深重苦难的人，事后往往会报告显著的积极变化。这可能包括对生活更深的欣赏、更牢固的关系、新的优先事项、增强的个人力量感，有时甚至是真正深刻的精神发展。当然，这并不总是会发生。
We don't want to make like a mass generalization that anyone who goes through trauma is going to come out better than before. But psychologically, from their description, this does make sense in some cases. Eating rock bottom, again, disrupts the old ways of being. There are teens, the identities that no longer serve us. You really have to evaluate, hey, what do I really care about? What do I really believe in? Is this discomfort a sign that I meant for more? One final way that we can understand this just to give you a few explanations is through the lens of crisis theory.
我们不想做一个大范围的概括，认为任何经历过创伤的人都会比以前变得更好。但从心理学上讲，根据他们的描述，在某些情况下这确实讲得通。跌入谷底，再次打破了旧的生存方式。有青少年，那些不再服务于我们的身份。你真的必须评估，嘿，我真正关心的是什么？我真正相信的是什么？这种不适感是我注定要成就更多事情的信号吗？为了给你一些解释，我们可以理解这一点的最后一个视角是通过危机理论的镜头。
this idea is that when a person faces a crisis so overwhelming that old coping strategies no longer work, they are forced to develop new ones. In other words, we are pushed to a point where we really have to see how deeply can go and we really have to encounter and really acknowledge and appreciate every single strength that we may have, every single skill that we may have in our toolkit. And the theory is that that actually makes us feel better or more capable in the long run. I've been really into ultramarathon documentaries recently and just like ultramarathoning in general as an observer, not a participant, obviously. And something that I've noticed in these documentaries is that so many of these athletes talk about this idea of the pain cave. I first
这个想法是，当一个人面临大到旧的应对策略不再起作用的危机时，他们就会被迫开发出新的策略。换句话说，我们被推到了一个不得不真正去审视自己能挖掘得多深的地步，我们必须真正去面对、真正认可并感激我们工具箱中可能拥有的每一个力量、每一个技能。而这个理论认为，从长远来看，这实际上会让我们感觉更好或更有能力。我最近迷上了超级马拉松纪录片，而且作为一个旁观者——显然不是参与者——我只是单纯喜欢超级马拉松这项运动。我在这些纪录片中注意到的一件事是，许多运动员都谈到了“痛苦之洞”这个概念。我第一次
heard about it from Courtney Dorwater, who is my dream guest. by the way, just the coolest woman ever. If anyone has a hookup, she is my number one dream guest. This woman is so cool. She's like one of the best ultramarathon runners, male or female in the world. And she describes the pain cave
听说这个词是从考特尼·多沃特（Courtney Dauwalter）那里，顺便说一句，她是我梦寐以求的嘉宾，简直是史上最酷的女性。如果有人能搭上线，她绝对是我心目中的头号梦想嘉宾。这个女人太酷了。她是世界上最优秀的超级马拉松运动员之一，不论男女。她将“痛苦之洞”
as this like point in a race where every single part of you wants to give up. Every single fiber of you is saying, please, can we quit? And yet you find this new reserve of energy and motivation and you push through. And that is when you discover this whole new level of what you're capable of, but also of who you are. And I love that idea.
描述为比赛中的一个阶段，在这个阶段中，你身上的每一个部分都想放弃。你的每一根神经都在说：求求了，我们能退赛吗？然而，你却能找到一股新的能量和动力储备，然后坚持挺过去。正是在那个时候，你发现了自己能力的全新高度，同时也发现了全新的自我。我太喜欢这个想法了。
Like, I don't, to be fair, I don't ever want to be in that situation. Like this woman is running like 500 miles, which I don't even, I can't even compute how actually long that is. But it's so fascinating to see other people discuss it and to see how other people have discovered this. Maybe that's really what this moment is for you. You're in the pain cave. What can you discover about yourself? So a really important caveat here for people who are experiencing addiction, there is definitely this really strange rhetoric online that says that the only way to overcome
老实说，我其实永远都不想处于那种境地。这个女人居然能跑上 500 英里，这简直超出了我的理解能力，我甚至无法想象那到底有多长。但看到其他人讨论这个话题，并了解其他人是如何发现这一点的，真的非常迷人。也许这正是此刻对你的意义所在。你正身处痛苦之洞。你能发现关于自己的什么呢？这里有一个非常重要的注意事项，对于那些正在经历成瘾问题的人来说，网络上确实有一种非常奇怪的论调，声称克服
your addiction is to find your rock bottom first. A lot of people talk about, you know, what was the moment when you really realized you needed to change? What was the moment where you hit rock bottom where, you know, you did something terrible to your family or you did something morally despicable or, you know, something that disgusted you and that in itself was like a catalyst for change. I do think that sometimes this can be very unhelpful. Firstly, who gets to decide or define what that rock bottom is?
成瘾的唯一方法是先找到自己的人生谷底。许多人都在谈论，你知道的，那个让你真正意识到自己需要改变的时刻是什么？你跌入谷底的那个时刻是怎样的，比如，你对家庭做了可怕的事情，或者你做了道德上令人鄙视的事情，或者你知道的，某件让你感到恶心的事情，而这本身就成了改变的催化剂。我确实认为，有时这种说法会非常没有帮助。首先，谁来决定或定义什么才叫跌入谷底？
And secondly, it also means that people really struggling with addiction, what they may find is that they feel like they have to push further in order to recover. So like aside from the clear health risks of this, people waiting for this elusive rock bottom point may find that it never comes, may find that they can always go deeper, may find themselves further isolating themselves or burning bridges or tunneling further into their addiction to get to this point so that they can rebuild. So if you are facing challenges related to addiction, I just want to say you do not need to wait until the crisis point to get help or to change. Same with mental health as well. At any stage, the moment that you realize, hey, this is really not working for me, this doesn't feel good, why am I doing this? My life isn't happy. You can say to yourself, this is my rock bottom. You don't have to wait until it meets or surpasses someone else's story of rock bottom to be able to get help.
其次，这也意味着那些与成瘾做激烈斗争的人可能会觉得，为了康复，他们必须把自己逼得更深。因此，除了这带来的明显健康风险之外，那些等待这个难以捉摸的谷底的人可能会发现它永远不会到来，可能会发现自己总能陷得更深，可能会发现自己进一步将自己孤立起来、断绝人际关系，或者在成瘾的泥潭里越陷越深，以至于为了能够重建生活而不得不触及这个点。因此，如果你正面临与成瘾相关的挑战，我只想说，你不必等到危机爆发才去寻求帮助或做出改变。心理健康也是如此。在任何阶段，当你突然意识到：“嘿，这真的不适合我，这感觉不好，我为什么要这么做？我的生活并不快乐。”你就可以对自己说：“这就是我的谷底。”你不需要等到它达到或超过别人的谷底故事，才能够去寻求帮助。
So although rock bottom, as I've described it, can be seen as transformative, I would urge you if you are struggling with mental health, with addiction. Rock bottom isn't a requirement for change. It's not at all. With that being said, if you are here right now, if you are at or near rock bottom, the question really becomes, how do you climb out? I'm sorry, I have to say it. I can't give you an instant fix. and I cannot give you a neat five-step plan that's going to magically restore everything in your life that has been removed or that you have lost maybe for a reason.
因此，尽管正如我所描述的那样，谷底可以被视为具有变革意义，但如果你正在与心理健康问题、成瘾问题作斗争，我要敦促你：跌入谷底并不是改变的必经之路。绝不是这样的。话虽如此，如果你现在就在这里，如果你正处于或接近人生谷底，真正的问题就变成了：你该如何爬出来？抱歉，我不得不这么说。我无法给你一个立竿见影的解决办法，
But I am going to give you some tools of how to make a start. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
我也无法为你提供一个整洁的五步计划，来神奇地恢复你生活中已经被剥夺的一切，或者那些你可能因为某种原因而失去的东西。但我会为你提供一些如何迈出第一步的工具。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家超越那些主导着健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it.
我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 IHeart Radio 上的 TWO percent，也可在 Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗丝（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什和金·卡戴珊（Little Kim）到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰伊（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。在每一集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Then you're finishing that sentence.
其中包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，畅谈 80 年代的快克（crack）毒品。坦白说，1984 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊一聊快克，不过为了让大家知道我的意思……我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在甚至把艾滋病也摆上台面了。然后你接着说那句话。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black. black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the
是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。黑人群体。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你的主持人、你最喜爱的治疗师基尔·加姆斯（Keer Games）。为了致敬心理健康意识月，我将结合十多年来自己在心理健康领域的经验，与众多不可思议的嘉宾展开对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某种
thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kea, games is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and
事物时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，甚至不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是盯着记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世上当个好人很重要，还是说你当好人只是因为你害怕？因为这是两种完全不同的动机，兄弟。确实如此。这也是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能够真正地去做一个好人。加入我和基尔·加姆斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并
listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻之中。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了他故事中惊人的矛盾之处。这就开启了一场长达多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你对这份特定的测试作假了两次。你在某些地方对这份特定的测试作假了两次，对吗？我作假测试了一次。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens
他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男性：格雷格·阿莱斯皮（Greg Alespie）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑子直接炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）
finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts,
终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因涉嫌欺诈罪已被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 Iheart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts，
or wherever you get your podcasts. First, and some people won't like that I'm going to say this, but first, let yourself grieve and show some self-pity. Let yourself be sad for yourself. I think this sounds and feels counterintuitive because the current culture around us really forces this toxic positivity onto us all and tells us that you are not supposed to let yourself suffer or to feel hard emotions or to feel bad for yourself.
或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。首先——有些人可能不会喜欢我接下来要说的话——但首先，允许自己去悲伤，流露一些自我怜悯。允许自己为自己感到难过。我认为这听起来和感觉起来都有些违反直觉，因为我们周围的现行文化实际上将这种有毒的积极性强加给我们所有人，并告诉我们，你不应该让自己受苦，不应该感受艰难的情绪，也不应该为自己感到难过。
Suppressing emotions doesn't mean they disappear. It doesn't mean they don't exist. It actually just makes them even stronger and likely to pop up in other ways. If you're in this position, you've likely had to let go of a lot. You have likely lost a lot. You have likely really suffered. Grieve these parts. Feel those emotions. Maybe it's also a way to counteract this numb state that you found yourself in. You can't process an emotion if you never feel it. So if you're at rock bottom, you're allowed to sit in self-pity for a little while. That is part of acceptance. It's also part of processing and therefore being able to act and move on from this moment. Second, we've talked about this a few times. Acknowledge that this is your rock bottom. Narrative psychology shows us that
压抑情绪并不意味着它们会消失。这并不意味着它们不存在。它实际上只会让情绪变得更加强烈，并更有可能以其他方式爆发出来。如果你处于这种境地，你很可能不得不放下了很多东西。你很可能已经失去了很多。你很可能真的承受了很多痛苦。为这些部分感到悲伤吧。去感受那些情绪。也许这也是一种对抗你发现自己身处的那种麻木状态的方法。如果你从不感受情绪，你就无法处理情绪。因此，如果你正处于人生谷底，你完全可以允许自己沉浸在自我怜悯中一段时间。这是接纳的一部分。这也是处理情绪的一部分，唯有如此，你才能采取行动并从这个时刻走出来。其次，我们已经讨论过好几次了。承认这就是你的底谷。叙事心理学向我们表明，
the way we frame our life stories shapes our well-being and how we view our lives. And that is incredibly important. When you say to yourself, yes, this is it. This is my rock bottom. You're not just naming your pain, which is obviously important, but you're also situating it. So it becomes a chapter of your life, not the whole book. And that shift in perspective from, this is the end, my life sucks, to this is just part of my story, an important part of my story, the dark night of my soul, can soften the pain that you're feeling, or at least give it a meaning or a reason. It transforms rock bottom from this infinite pit that we know comes from future discounting into this definable moment that allows you to kind of almost project into the future and realize
我们构建人生故事的方式塑造了我们的幸福感以及我们如何看待生活。这极其重要。当你对自己说：“是的，就是这样。这就是我的人生谷底。”你不仅是在给你的痛苦命名（这显然很重要），而且你还在对它进行定位。这样它就成了你人生中的一个章节，而不是整本书。这种观点的转变——从“这就是终点，我的人生糟透了”到“这只是我故事的一部分，是我故事中重要的一部分，是我灵魂的黑夜”——可以减轻你正在感受的痛苦，或者至少赋予它某种意义或理由。它将人生谷底从一个我们知道源于未来折现的无底深渊，转变为一个可定义的时刻，让你几乎可以将其投射到未来，并意识到
that in hindsight maybe I'm going to see this differently maybe not right now but maybe in the future next seek out what we call little islands of competence at rock bottom everything feels overwhelming. Where do I start? What's the first step? What do I do? The future is very blurry. The big picture is way too much to handle. So don't. Don't handle the big picture. Focus on the small winds. Focus on one thing you can do today that is going to increase your coping, increase your productivity, increase your relationships, improve things for you. You don't need to put the added pressure on yourself to like overhaul your life in a night or in a week or to bounce back and be like the happiest person alive and that there is some kind of timeline that you need
事后看来，也许我会用不同的眼光看待这一切；也许现在不会，但将来会的。接下来，寻找我们所谓的“微小胜任感之岛”。在人生谷底，一切都让人感到不知所措。我从哪里开始？第一步是什么？我该做什么？未来非常模糊。宏大的全景让人难以招架。所以，别去管它。不要去管那个宏大的全景。专注于微小的胜利。专注于今天你能做的、一件能够提高你的应对能力、提高你的生产力、改善你的人际关系、让事情对你有所好转的事情。你不需要给自己施加额外的压力，想要在一夜之间或一周内彻底改变你的生活，或者反弹成为世界上最快乐的人，并且觉得好像有一个时间表，规定你必须
to get over this within a month or it's going to last forever. Just pick one small thing you think you can control and do that for yourself today. Cook yourself a meal, take yourself for a walk, journal for two minutes. Even tiny moments of success begin to restore your sense of agency, competence and confidence. They remind you like, hey, yeah, I can't control this big, terrible mess. that I'm in, but I can decide that I'm going to go and order ice cream tonight. I can decide that I'm going to get out of the house and do some exercise. I can decide that I'm going to book this appointment with my doctor. Those things snowball into bigger things over time. Fourth, and maybe this
在一个月内从阴影中走出来，否则这种状态就会永远持续下去。只要挑选一件你认为自己可以掌控的小事，今天就为自己把它做好。给自己做顿饭，带自己去散个步，写两分钟日记。哪怕是微小的成功时刻，也能开始恢复你的自主感、胜任感和自信心。它们会提醒你：“嘿，是的，我无法控制我所处这个巨大而可怕的混乱局面，但我可以决定今晚去点一盒冰淇淋。我可以决定出门去锻炼一下。我可以决定预约我的医生。”随着时间的推移，这些事情会像滚雪球一样变成更大的成就。第四点，也许这
actually should have been third because I think it links to our, I think it links to one of the things, one of the tips I gave above. But just see your situation in the context that it's actually existing, rather than the context that you've created for it. Zoom out a little bit. It's natural to feel like no one could possibly understand what you're going through. But I think this is one way in which comparison might actually be a good thing.
其实应该排在第三位，因为我认为它与我们的……我认为它与我上面给出的某一个建议、某一条提示有关。但很简单，要以它实际存在的背景来看待你的处境，而不是以你为它凭空想象出来的背景来看待。把视角稍微拉远一点。感觉没有人能够理解你的经历是很自然的。但我认为，这正是比较可能实际上是一件好事的一个方面。
It can be really helpful to look at others who face similar struggles to normalize your own experience. You know, a few months back when I released that episode talking about my mental breakdown, oh my God, I was so scared and I was also in a terrible place,
去看那些面临类似挣扎的人，对于正常化你自己的经历会非常有帮助。你知道的，几个月前，当我发布那集谈论我精神崩溃的播客时，天哪，我当时吓坏了，而且我的处境也非常糟糕，
but the amount of comments and messages I received from people saying it had helped or that they were going through the same thing was amazing, and guess what, it made me feel better? Just the idea that this was not something that I had to experience alone or that I was not the only person in the world who had this feeling felt great because I didn't feel lonely or isolated in my experience. So looking to other podcasts, to books, to interviews, whatever it is of people who are going through the same thing, they are all social opportunities for validation of what you're going through. They are also living proof that other people have had challenges and they've found their way through.
但收到大量评论和信息让我感到很惊讶，人们说它提供了帮助，或者他们也正在经历同样的事情。你猜怎么着？这让我感觉好多了。仅仅是“这不是我一个人必须经历的事情”或者“我不是世界上唯一有这种感觉的人”这种想法，就让我感觉棒极了，因为在我的经历中，我并不感到孤独或与世隔绝。因此，去寻找其他播客、书籍、采访，无论是什么，只要是经历过同样事情的人的分享，它们都是对你所经历的事情进行社会化验证的机会。它们也是活生生的证明，表明其他人也曾面临挑战，并且他们已经找到了出路。
That's vicarious learning, right? A vicarious form of validation of like, hey, if they were okay, maybe I will be as well. Last but certainly not least, change your environment. I'm not saying move to a new city straight away. In fact, there have been studies that have shown that your problems will follow you there. But sometimes you just need small environmental shifts that signal to your brain that are fresh start its underway. And also, maybe you can move to a new city. It might not fix all your problems.
这就是替代性学习，对吧？一种替代性的验证形式，就像是：“嘿，如果他们能安然无度过，也许我也行。”最后但同样重要的一点是：改变你的环境。我并不是说让你立刻搬到一个新城市。事实上，已经有研究表明，你的问题会跟着你一起到那里去。但有时你只需要一些微小的环境转变，向你的大脑发出一个信号：新的开始正在进行中。而且，也许你确实可以搬到一个新城市。它可能无法解决你所有的问题，
Maybe it all fix one problem and maybe that one problem was where everything is stemming from. Just change your surroundings. Environmental psychology shows us that our environment shapes our mindset. So rearranging your room, buying you bedding, taking a different route to work, spending more time in nature. These small cues can help break old associations and create space for new patterns because you're not in the same environment. They tell your brain and your nervous system, hey, things are different now. Look around us. Things are different, which does make change feel more possible.
也许它能解决一个问题，而那个问题可能正是所有问题的根源所在。只需改变你的周围环境。环境心理学向我们表明，环境塑造了我们的心态。因此，重新布置你的房间，买一套新床具，走一条不同的路线去上班，花更多的时间在大自然中。这些微小的线索可以帮助打破旧的联结，为新的模式创造空间，因为你不再处于相同的环境中。它们会告诉你的大脑和神经系统：“嘿，现在情况不同了。看看我们的周围。情况已经不一样了，”这确实会让改变显得更有可能实现。
making those really small changes in your routine leaves less room for old patterns and behaviours to resurface and that is what gives you a fresh approach to life rock bottom is truly terrifying it can feel like the end of everything we know and yet i want to remind you again across psychology philosophy across spirituality and religion and lived experience we see that it's not the end.
在你的日常生活中做出这些非常微小的改变，会给旧的模式和行为再次浮现留出更少空间，而这正是为你提供一种全新生活方式的途径。跌入谷底确实令人毛骨悚然，它感觉就像是我们所知的一切的终结。然而，我想再次提醒你，纵观心理学、哲学、精神世界与宗教以及生活经验，我们看到它并不是终点。
For a lot of people, it is the pivot. It's the threshold. It's the trampoline. If you are here right now, I promise you that there is a point in the future, there is a version of you in the future, looking at you right now thinking, gosh, I don't think they know how good it's going to get.
对许多人来说，它是转折点，是门槛，是蹦床。如果你现在就在这里，我向你保证，未来总有一个时刻，未来总有一个版本的你在看着现在的自己，心里想着：“天哪，我想他们根本不知道事情会变得多好。”
I don't think they know this isn't the end. Even if you can't see it yet, even if the fog hasn't lifted, transformation is possible and it happens slowly until you blink and you are just so grateful for the new life that you're going to find yourself in. I'll be the one to tell you that even if you don't believe it at the moment, you're going to be okay. I've been there. And sometimes when you hit rock bottom, literally the only way to go is up. You can't tunnel any deeper. Everyone has a point where they're like, they really hit their threshold for what they're able to tolerate or what life
我想他们不知道这并不是终点。即使你现在还看不到，即使迷雾还没有散去，转变是完全可能的，而且它会缓慢地发生，直到你眨眼之间，就会发现自己对所迎来的新生活感到无比感激。我来告诉你，即使你此刻并不相信，你也一定会没事的。我也曾经历过。有时，当你跌入谷底时，字面意思上唯一的出路就是向上。你不可能再往下挖更深了。每个人都有这样一个时刻，他们达到了自己所能忍受的极限，或者达到了生活
can give them. And then their luck begins to change or they begin to change. So I feel that for you. I know you're going to be okay. I know that this moment is terrible, but it's also influential. So just wishing you luck and wishing you happiness in the future and hoping that this episode resonated with you, whether you are in your 20s, in your 30s, in your 70s. I always feel like there's capacity for us to change and that these moments cannot be our whole life. So thank you so much for listening. I also appreciate everyone who DM'd me with their rock bottom experiences and contributed to this episode. I found them really quite emotional and revealing to read and they definitely informed how I approached this episode. So I appreciate you guys sharing with me. I also want to thank
所能给予他们的极限。然后他们的运气开始改变，或者他们开始改变。所以我能对你的感受感同身受。我知道你现在过得很糟糕，但这也是一个充满影响力的时刻。因此，我只想祝你好运，祝你未来幸福，并希望这一集能引发你的共鸣，无论你是处于二十多岁、三十多岁还是七十多岁。我总觉得我们身上总有改变的潜能，这些艰难时刻绝不能定义我们的一生。非常感谢大家的收听。我也非常感谢所有通过私信向我分享他们跌入谷底的经历并为本期节目做出贡献的人。阅读这些内容让我感到非常触动和深刻，它们无疑对我的这期节目的构思起到了指导作用。所以非常感谢你们与我分享。我还想感谢
our wonderful researcher Libby Colbert for her contributions. to this episode. She is just like the most fantastic individual and I'm so lucky that we have her on the team now. So thank you, Libby, for your research and for your fact checking and for finding some cool studies for this episode. As always, wherever you are listening right now, make sure that you are following along. Give us a review, give us a rating, especially if you're on Apple podcasts. Living a review really helps the show to grow. Yeah, and just find new people. So I would really appreciate if you feel called to do so if you would kindly do that. Make sure also that you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. It's a great way to kind of see what we're up to,
我们出色的研究员莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对本期节目的贡献。她简直是最棒的人，我非常幸运我们的团队现在能拥有她。所以，谢谢莉比，感谢你的调研和事实核查，以及为这期节目找到了一些很酷的研究。一如既往，无论你现在在哪里收听，请务必关注我们。给我们留个评价，打个分，特别是如果你在 Apple Podcasts 上收听的话。留下评价对节目的成长非常有帮助。是的，也能帮我们触达新的人群。因此，如果你愿意顺手做这件事，我将不胜感激。同时也请确保在 Instagram 上关注我们 @That Psychology Podcast。这是了解我们在做什么的好方法，
see updates, get summaries of these episodes and to ask questions or suggest episodes you may want to hear. So until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself, especially if you are in your rock bottom moment right now. We will talk very, very. soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app.
查看更新，获取这些节目的摘要，并提出问题或建议你可能想听的节目。那么，下次再见之前，请保持安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点，尤其是如果你现在正处于人生谷底的时刻。我们很快就会再次相聚。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我主持的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即 IHeartRadio 上的 TWO percent，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
也可在 Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定亲自动手。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话。
Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I got you, I got you. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English.
相信我，宝贝。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。我懂你，我懂你。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从 1979 年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。1984 年对我很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格利希。
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite
每一集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家们一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论 80 年代。1984 年是个疯狂的年份。那真是个疯狂的年份。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家过得怎么样？欢迎收听由你喜爱的
therapist and host, Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方都绝对不安全、无法开展的坦诚对话，而你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着一身盔甲。它向全世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the hard way》。这是一个 IHeart 播客。品质真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击转写中的任意句子即可留下评论。